d'abord est-ce que c'est un obama
nouveau qu'on a vus ou un retour à
l'ancien barack obama celui qu'on
connaissait je pense c'est celui qu'on a
vu depuis au début depuis 2008 2009 où
ce qu'on a senti obama ce moment là
beaucoup plus d'attaquer un nouveau
président il ya va pas subi l'idée fait
encore de novembre 2010 à cachan de les
présentant puis l'an 2014 avec la cena
qui tombait dans les mains des
républicains
donc ils contrôlent un peu toute la
législature une certaine façon donc mon
avis le contre attaque monsieur obama ce
soir
très fin mais plus que ça c'est comme
s'ils s'en occupe même pas ils s'en
occupent même pas parce qu'il me dit il
le répéter encore ce soir c'est le veto
qui voit poser si on voit attaquer les
mesures que j'ai pensé dans passé ou
même ce qui s'en vient
puis la question du décret peut
l'utiliser comme président savait déjà
finalement il ya aussi le défi auprès
des républicains
est ce que vous voulez gouverner vous
voulez pas gouverner que c'est un peu ça
qu'ils ont lancé comme défi
si vous voulez gouverner travailler avec
moi on va avancer pour l'ensemble la
population américain pas pour ça que
quand qui parle finalement de couper les
indes de couper les impôts de la classe
moyenne ça va être financé par
l'augmentation des impôts pour ceux qui
sont les plus riches aux états unis et
donc ça veut dire que ça ça va aider
l'ensemble de la population quasiment 80
% on peut dire de la classe moyenne
faut dire que celui qu'on voit touchée
que tafer puis il faudrait aussi quand
on dit classe moyenne aux états unis ça
inclut la classe ouvrière c'est un peu
plus larges comme définition qu'on a
fait ici avec néanmoins si le défi qu'a
lancé aux républicains la balle est dans
votre camp parce qu'il faudra il est ok
tu oui parce que l'élection du parti
tout à fait puis en plus de 100 ici que
la population a donné la majorité au
sénat autour du public 1 parce que on a
envoyé un message vous
et donc les autres qui dit nous on n'est
pas content de laisser monsieur obama
qui prête à gouverner lui a dit ce soir
moi je peux te gouverne ou encore
l'ensemble de la population américaine
et comme vous avez dit c'est la classe
moyenne qui subit la crise de 2005 6 7 8
qui ça va prendre encore plusieurs
années avant qu'ils aient le temps
finalement au point de départ des
immeubles dont une quinzaine d'années
donc c'est ça que vous venez pour son
ensemble de sa population
oui absolument
le chômage le chômage a baissé la
construction davantage nouvelle
automobile la construction
aussi il faut dire la création de 11
millions d'emplois même s'il faut dire
quand même que on peut pas dire que
c'est des qualités d'emplois les
salaires restent encore assez bars aux
états unis donc il ya travaillé sur ce
soit ce qu'on va augmenter en panne au
salaire minimum qui va aider les autres
salaires augmentent et les gaz
augmentait aussi mais son cycle et les
publics et en général depuis quelques
jours on dit on n'est pas intéressé à
rien de qu'est-ce qu'il faut dire là ça
va être un beau combat entre les deux
mais monsieur obama a une autre idée
derrière la tête pour ça qu'il fait ce
discours là ce soir
surtout ils ont incité mille ans et qui
finalement il veut créer les paramètres
qui va déterminer l'élection de 2005 qui
veut démontrer que si nous les
démocrates qui veulent à bien-être de
l'ensemble des populations américains et
pour vous les républicains vous
défendiez toujours les riches et donc ça
veut dire pour lui et tentant de définir
ces paramètres là au niveau du discours
qui s'en vient qui commence bientôt dans
quelques mois tout on peut dire le pré
primaires pour se livrer en temps de
campagne va commencer donc dans l'or
c'est une façon pour lui d'aider son
propre parti peut-être harbonnier la
présidence en 2005 très bien ce que tu
avais tu as merci beaucoup